if you've already heard of the
nurburgring uh then by all means uh
enjoy this video we've got uh an
interview behind the scenes some footage
of the place uh but also we have me
trying to explain the basics of it
while being driven round the
nordschleife the north loop by a
professional driver thank you andy
but if you haven't heard of the
nurburgring then it may surprise you
that one of the greatest most demanding
race tracks in the world is also just a
public toll road and if you want
you can just turn up and drive it
all right
i'm going to regret this let's do it
all right let's do it
there were always these three big
components so one that the notch life is
open for public then there's car testing
the big manufacturers are still testing
many many weeks every year here on the
nordschleife the new components the new
cars
and of course there's also racing normal
traffic rules apply here you have to
drive on the right you have to overtake
on the left but on most of the track
there is no speed limit and that's
because germany has no national speed
limit there are thousands of kilometers
of autobahn out there where you can
drive as fast as you safely can as long
as you're in control your vehicle speed
doesn't matter so legally this is just a
one-way toll road you go to the barrier
you pay your 25 euro you go through this
bit with the cones and the speed limit
and then
you are on the rig
oh yes
20.8 kilometers the nurburgring norjlife
is the longest permanent racetrack in
the world is in the most popular and
most famous racetracks in the world
comparable to indianapolis to monaco to
daytona but there are lots of safety
rules and the team here
oh my god the team here asked me to make
it clear that racing on the ring on days
like this is not allowed and you'll see
the cars ahead when we're on the
straights they indicate right they get
out of the way because legally on the
autobahn that's what you'd have to do
lap timers and dash cams are forbidden
i mean we've got special permission for
these cameras my
god
we've got special permission but none of
these cars should have dash cams or
timers because it is just too dangerous
to
it is too dangerous
to have a clock ticking even either on
your dashboard or in your head the track
is unforgiving
if you come off here you're not rolling
onto grass you're not rolling onto
gravel you are hitting a barrier or
worse you're hitting oh that was a drop
you're hitting someone else the track
oh it has jumps it has sections where
you will oh my god get
what roller coaster fans would call air
time not quite injected time but air
time
everyone is able to drive of course
everyone who is sticking to the rules of
our driving um standards
and of course which cars finally fit to
our standards 2.8 tons is the max people
driving here run with their porsche but
you've also got a family uh driving in
their van here around there is a story
that if you crash then the nurburgring
team will present you with a bill for
damage for every half hour the safety
car had to be out here for every half
hour that
they had to repair the track for every
meter of crash barrier that you have
damaged that story is absolutely 100
true if you are conscious you will be
delivered a bill but it turns out that's
also true in most of the world if you
crash on a british road then the local
highways authority will send out a bill
it's just that it'll go to your
insurance company not to you oh g-forces
but insurance other than
very very good german insurance it won't
cover you for the ring nearly every
insurance company particularly those
outside germany has a clause in there
that specifically excludes driving here
even if you are
just a tourist
in case of a heavier accident then the
track gets closed
in case of a
normal incident like a technical
breakdown then it might be that it's
just getting under yellow first of all
we've got marshals around and permanent
contact to our operators here in the
entrance we've got an emergency number
and what we are now having also from
2021 on is that we are starting to
provide the notch level with camera
operators
so that is a speed limit we have just
hit a speed limit for this corner
and i can see why
and then as soon as you pass this line
yep off we go
two years ago we had a statistics that
every 15 000 kilometers an incident is
happening on the nurburgring but an
incident might also be a car losing
fluid some technical issues but also of
course an accident
i think the biggest difference is when
you've got an accident on a normal road
it takes quite a time until you've got
some emergency here we've got around 60
people
of track safety and track operators
making this track as safe as possible
there's a banked turn
there isn't another racetrack like the
nordschleife it's just built into the
landscape normally landscapes are
constructed for racetracks
out of the way
it is so challenging because it's so
narrow and it's so long the barriers are
so close to the racetrack and yeah i
guess that's what it makes the
challenging but what also the drivers
love little jump three two one hip oh
and boy the line
wow
i hope you enjoyed it oh yes
that was incredible i have never done
anything like that before i i like
racing now i i like race tracks
wow
i
every time every time i've done
something like this i've gone in
thinking i'm gonna hate it i've gone in
thinking it's gonna be terrible and i'm
going to be terrified
and every time i've loved it
yes
i loved every second of that i want to
do that again
thank you so much to andy my driver
thank you so much to all the team here
at the nurburgring
oh that's wonderful